we're told the table gives the amounts
of materials
i are recycled so we have the different
materials here and then it gives the
various amounts how many kilograms of
paper and aluminum did aya recycle so
pause this video and see if you can
figure this out
okay so we were thinking about paper and
aluminum so
paper is right over here she recycled
277 kilograms of paper and aluminum is
right over here she recycled 134
kilograms of aluminum and so we want the
combination or the sum of paper and
aluminum so it's going to be
kilograms plus 134
kilograms so we really need to figure
out what 277 plus 134 is and in multiple
videos we have talked about how there's
many different ways of approaching this
we could say well let's just break up
the 134. we could start at actually let
me do this on a number line that
sometimes is a fun thing to do so if we
were to just say this is our number line
and we're going to start at 277
right over there
so first we could add a 100
because we have 100 right over there so
let's do that if we add a hundred
so plus 100 where does it get us well if
we add 100 here we get to 300
377 so 300 and i'll just write
and then we could add
3 tens or 30.
so then we're going to add 30 so let's
add 30
so plus
30 what does that get us
so this is interesting if you
add
30 to 370
you would get to
400 and then we have another 7 there so
that gets us to 407
so then we get to
407 and once again this is just one way
to try to think about it and then last
but not least we could add the four so
then you say
we're there right now and then we add
plus four and seven plus four is eleven
so four hundred and seven plus four is
four hundred and eleven so how many
kilograms of paper
and aluminum did i recycle would be 411
kilograms kilo
kilograms and we're done